What's in the box?
Whatever it is must be pretty important,...
...because I've traveled with it, moved it, from apartment to apartment to apartment.
Sound familiar?
Did you know that we Americans have about three times the amount of space we did 50 years ago?
Three times.
So you'd think, with all this extra space, we'd have plenty of room for all our stuff.
Nope.
There's a new industry in town,...
...a 22-billion-dollar, 2.2-billion square foot industry: that of personal storage.
So we've got triple the space, but we've become such good shoppers that we need even more space.
So, where does this lead?
Lots of credit card debt, huge environmental footprints,...
...and perhaps not coincidentally, our happiness levels flatlined over the same 50 years.
Well, I'm here to suggest there's a better way, that less might actually equal more.
I bet most of us have experienced at some point the joys of less:...
...college - in your dorm, traveling - in a hotel room, camping,...
...where you've got basically nothing, maybe a boat.
Whatever it was for you, I bet that, among other things,...
....this gave you a little more freedom, a little more time.
So, I'm going to suggest that less stuff and less space are going to equal a smaller footprint.
It's actually a great way to save you some money.
And it's going to give you a little more ease in your life.
So, I started a project called LifeEdited at lifeedited.org to further this conversation...
...and to find some great solutions in this area.
First up: crowdsourcing my 420 square feet apartment in Manhattan with partners Mutopo and Jovoto.com.
I wanted it all - home office, sit-down dinner for 10, room for guests, and all my kitesurfing gear.
With over 300 entries from around the world, I got it, my own little jewel box.
By buying a space that was 420 square feet instead of 600, immediately I'm saving 200 grand.
Smaller space is going to make for smaller utilities,...
... save some more money there, but also a smaller footprint.
And because it's really designed around an edited set of possessions,...
...my favorite stuff and really designed for me, I'm really excited to be there.
So how can you live little?
Three main approaches.
First of all, you have to edit ruthlessly.
We've got to clear the arteries of our lives.
And that shirt that I hadn't worn in years?
It's time for me to let it go.
We've got to cut the extraneous out of our lives,...
...and we've got to learn to stem the inflow.
We need to think before we buy.
Ask ourselves, "Is that really going to make me happier?
Truly?"
By all means, we should buy and own some great stuff.
But we want stuff that we're going to love for years, not just stuff.